the giant Consumer Electronic Show gets
underway in Las Vegas this coming week
highlighting many innovations that will
eventually turn up in our lives and the
very latest tech and science trends for
the year ahead
are the topic of an article published
just this morning by Wired magazine here
to talk about it is Wired's
editor-in-chief Nick Thompson good
morning good morning so see us what does
it really mean to us these days well CES
is the giant Electronic Show I'm flying
there Monday morning off to Las Vegas
what you see is just an absolute mess of
gadgets and in it a lot of stuff that
will never work that's absurd and a lot
of stuff that we'll all be using in two
or three years you get a little bit of a
glimpse of the future and so the
challenge there is to find ok this is
real this is not yeah what will fail and
what will make it exactly feels like
we've been talking about augmented and
virtual reality for a while in gaming
and other industries what might we see
maybe there this year as we look at it
well I actually think that augmented
reality will be something we're gonna
see a lot of I think that five years
sure now augmented reality will be huge
so augmented reality is where you put on
glasses or you hold up a phone and think
of pokey [ __ ] and it adds something
electronic to the world around you and
it hasn't really worked in that many
applications but with 5g so much faster
technology to stream information to and
from your phones or your glasses or your
wrists or wherever I think we're gonna
see amazing stuff with this one thing a
lot of people are talking about right
now is foldable technology yeah and this
is not just phones how is that playing
out what else can be used as foldable
technology so it's really interesting as
that glass gets stronger and thinner so
you can bend it and make it more
flexible so your phone can turn into a
laptop less likely to break in your
pocket but there are other ways that
gets all the champagne yeah yeah but
there are other ways it could be really
interesting if you think about foldable
solar panels for example right the
ability to put them over the I don't
know the arch of a house or put them on
a car right you can think about
applications that will be really
interesting in fighting climate change
which you know one of the great
challenges and what that could mean in
the developing world yeah what it could
mean in the developing world as you have
more flexible products then we have
stronger batteries where you can take
technology is just as important as what
you can do with technology
okay so 3d printing this is always sort
of scares me because the innovation in
that area just keeps growing and growing
what are we likely likely to see there
well 3d print
there's been a lot of hype over a year
after year and it's always been a little
slow the question with 3d printing is
what materials can you put in the
printer what can you get out and how
much will it cost I think you're gonna
see incremental change this year but I
think in the future you'll use 3d
printing not just for prototypes but
actually for mass production
you mentioned 5g before and I feel like
I've seen it and then there was like
fake 5g and the real 5g where are we
with 5g now so I think this is the year
you'll actually get 5g
so 5g is a communications protocol where
information is sent basically over
different radio waves right where it
allows much more information to be sent
much more quickly and so what we'll see
this year at CES is a lot of technology
for making 5g work but the interesting
question what are the things that will
be built on 5g when 4G came that's what
brought us Instagram it's what brought
us over was a whole bunch of stuff we
hadn't imagined and that stuff didn't
work
with slower phones once you had fast
phones oh then you can download pictures
seamlessly oh look you can share them oh
Instagram right so what happens with 5g
that's what we're gonna get a glimpse of
at CES so my fast does that mean we're
streaming 4G versus 5g or downloading
something let's say 10x in the in the
beginning I mean right now it'll be sort
of one and a half - but then 10 possibly
fifth I'm gonna go get a new phone again
oh you're gonna get a new phone every
time Thompson thank you very much
you